ja viel länger ist beschäftigt mich seit
einigen Tagen da bin ich irgendwie rein
geraten in eine Szene in die man nicht
so oft in seinem Leben gerät und auch
nicht geraten will da können wir Sie
noch mal sehen Oliver Pocher kriegt
einen Schlag ins Gesicht und ich sitze
nebendran eines jetzt weiter sitzt
Christoph Daum und dann saß ich da und
wenn ich mir die Szene so angucke dann
frage ich mich bis heute warum Klaus
bist du eigentlich nicht dazwischen
gesprungen warum bist du das jetzt
geblieben okay ich sage ein bisschen was
und ich kann hinterher auch analysieren
da spätestens waren ich sitze da der der
das der Daumen und da hinten der
übernächste bin ich also ein Meter 50
entfernt mit Abstand aber in dem Fall
eben sozusagen wir haben keine Maske an
keiner hat deine Maske an da waren alle
getestet dieses jedenfalls aber was mich
wirklich was mich wirklich
umtreibt ist dieser Blick auf mich
selbst warum ich da nicht eingeschritten
bin und das kann man sich jetzt schön
reden und sagen ja die Situation war
dann erklärt oder dafür sind ja Ordner
zuständig und das stimmt auch alles für
den Moment danach aber dieser Moment
dieser Moment wo der Schläger vor Oliver
Pocher steht Oliver Pocher ist schutzlos
da würde ich heute sagen
verstehe ich mich selber nicht warum ich
da nicht dazwischen gegangen bin und das
obwohl ich oft ja Zivilcourage von
anderen verlange und das gibt mir
irgendwie den Gedanken mit dass wenn
eine ungewöhnliche Situation keiner hat
es erwartet ist gegen wahnsinnig schnell
passiert wenn eine Extremsituation
passiert dann reagiert man
offensichtlich anders als ein lieb ist
und deshalb ist es mir in wirkliches
Anliegen Oliver Pocher einmal zuzurufen
Olli sorry dass ich dir nicht geholfen
habe das nächste Mal springen wir dir
alle zur Seite das ist eine spannende
Frage jetzt die würde ich direkt mal
gerne ein Herr Palma spielen Stichwort
Zivilcourage Herr Palma hätten sie denn
eingegriffen und verstehen Sie warum
Herr Strunz sich jetzt schlecht fühlt
dass er es nicht getan hat
also das zweite das tue ich ich verstehe
das dass man sich dann nachher fragt
hätte ich was machen können aber wenn
ich diese Videoaufnahmen mir zu sehe
dann habe ich den Eindruck das kam so
aus dem nichts so überraschend dass er
quasi die Gabe der Vorstellung hätte
haben müssen und dagegen irgendwas zu
tun das war doch gar nicht möglich da
einzugreifen wie kann man denn wissen
dass dieser Typ da da herkommt und den
einfach umhaut dass ich ich kann das gar
nicht fassen dass sowas passiert also ja
bis zu dem bis zu dem Schlag stimmt das
da könnte man wirklich nichts machen das
war vollkommen überraschend dann ist
auch noch finde ich eine Zehntelsekunde
konsterniert sein und aber dann gibt es
diese merkwürdige Situationen nach dem
Schlag wo ein
Opfer das wird Oliver Pocher nicht gern
über sich hören aber es war in der
Situation so ein
Opfer schutzlos da ist und ein Täter vor
ihm steht und da muss man eigentlich
dazwischen gehen übrigens wichtig nicht
meine Kritik an mir selber ist jetzt
nicht dass ich den hätte schlagen sollen
aber schützend dazwischen gehen das ist
doch das was wir uns eigentlich dafür
wünschen und ich frage mich echt warum
das ausgesetzt hat vom Ende her
betrachtet freue ich mich dass jetzt
nicht was wahnsinnig schlimmes passiert
ist Oliver Pocher klagt zwar wohl über
Ohrenschmerzen aber man konnte auch in
der Situation schon sehen dass er jetzt
also kein großen Schaden davon getragen
hat in Sicherheit war dass dieser Fett
Comedy heißt der wie ich gelernt habe
Schläger auch keinen anderen mehr hauen
wird also das war bereinigt aber dieser
eine Moment macht mir schon also dem
sehe ich dauernd vor mir und denkt wow
wie oft hast du es dir angeschaut das
Video 100 mal 200 Mal angehalten
ja der Moment nicht
ja aber mich wird wirklich interessieren
sozusagen ob wir von anderen immer was
verlangen sozusagen Zivilcourage und
dann kommt man selber in so einem Moment
und sieht ein Video auf dem man das
sitzt und irgendwie sagt was soll das
sage ich da glaube ich was soll das aber
könnte es nicht sein dass Sie falls der
Anstalten gemacht hätte weiter zu dann
eingeschritten das würde ich mir auch
aber es gibt ja den Moment schon vorher
es gibt den Moment den schutzmoment ich
würde auch sagen wenn wenn der sozusagen
meiner Frau eine geknalltete wäre ich
wahrscheinlich sofort aufgestanden die
auch eine geknallt womit war bei Will
Smith werden ja also so viel quasi
archaische Intuition würde ich mir noch
zutrauen ja da ist auch Schluss mit
Pazifismus und umso mehr wunder ich mich
an der Stelle
dass das so gar nichts war ganz
merkwürdig ich glaube das war
Schockstarre für mich sieht es aus wie
ist das kommt
erstmal gar nicht achten aber ich finde
es auch eine Mauer ich freue mich dass
ich so deuten aber ich finde es für mich
eine Mauer Entschuldigung ja wenn das
alle Leute die nicht helfen sagen ja
dabei irgendwie ein Schockstarre da im
Bus ist irgendwie eine Jacke geklaut
worden von zwei Typen uh da war ich in
Schockstarre ah die Frau die da
irgendwie blöd angequatscht und
angegriffen wurde von jemand Obst da war
ich so in Schockstarre also ich
bewegt mich wirklich also auch in der
Hinsicht was man von anderen verlangt
also kann man von anderen eigentlich
verlangen was man selber nicht bringt
eine Psychologie die ja jeder von uns
hat jeder reagiert anders auf so etwas
vielleicht handelt auch jeder in so
einer Situation anders waren sie denn
schon mal in so einer Situation nein
aber ich würde auch nicht irgendwo
hingehen weil Oliver Pocher herumsitzt
und geboxt
nein wissen sie das ganze es ist
wirklich völlig wurscht so aber wenn sie
mich schon fragen
es ist eigentlich nichts passiert das
was sie da gesehen passiert in den
Berliner Verkehrsbetrieben fast täglich
und nur selten kommt es als fünfzeilige
Meldung im Tagesspiegel an die
Öffentlichkeit also
das ist halt der Fluch der Prominenz das
ist Oliver Pocher erwischt hat aber ich
möchte mich so gerne an eure Aufregung
beteiligen aber es will mir nicht
gelingen der hat es auch noch der der
Schläger hat es auch noch filmen lassen
ja was sonst um es dann sehen wir ja das
machen
und sozusagen das passiert natürlich
wahrscheinlich auf dem Schulhof auch
dauern hat das live gestreamt nein das
hat er nicht so das hat dann war es ein
Amateur dann gilt es nicht ich mag ihr
Zugangs nicht immer voll klein ja also
ich denke Sie haben ja auch ein Stück
weit selbst Zweifel und Fragen sich ja
kann man das von anderen erwarten wenn
man das selber nicht liefert ich denke
das auch Zivilcourage schon ist wenn man
beispielsweise auf der Straße sieht wie
einer Frau Gewalt angetan wird
beispielsweise und man nimmt den Hörer
in die Hand und ruft die Polizei auch
das Courage ist man muss sich nicht
sozusagen dahin stellen und zurückhauen
ich denke das kann man nicht von jedem
erwarten aber vielleicht auch ich glaube
auch dass ich teile den Eindruck dass es
vielleicht wirklich so ein Schockmoment
ist einfach weil wir man ist nicht in
diesem Kontext man ist auf einer
Veranstaltung und dann passiert
irgendwas womit man wirklich gar nicht
gerechnet hat aber ich bleibe bei ihrem
Beispiel
eine Frau wird was angetan man
beobachtet es ist es eher meiner
wirklich ausreichend dann zum Hörer zu
greifen die Polizei anzurufen die dann
wenn es schnell geht in drei oder fünf
Minuten da ist da kann ja wer weiß was
passiert sein also muss nicht doch auch
ein ein gester sein sich selber
einzubringen und vielleicht sogar ein
Gefahr zu begeben um einem anderen zu
helfen und ja schon sie sind wirklich
ein Idealist und das was sie gerade
beschreiben
es wurde Zeit eine einer musste Anfang
machen nein das was jetzt beschreiben
ist ungefähr der Zustand normalen
Gesellschaft in den 20er 30er Jahren
aber inzwischen sind wir gründlich
pazifiziert worden inzwischen gilt ja
Selbstverteidigung sogar als eine
aggressive Haltung und was mich im
negativen Sinne wahnsinnig beeindruckt
hat bei dieser lustigen Silvesternacht
in Köln 2015 glaube ich ich habe lange
fast alles darüber gelesen weil mich
eine Frage beschäftigte als die Frauen
da belästigt angegrabscht und befingert
worden die waren da allein unterwegs ja
da waren kein Männer dabei keine Freunde
keine Verwandten keine Eltern
Geschwister von Männern weil in der
ganzen Berichterstattung ist es nicht
aufgefallen nicht die Rede das heißt in
einer Gesellschaft die so gründlich
pazifiziert wurde dass selbst in einer
solchen Situation die man sich traut
zuzuschlagen als ich das gesehen habe
dachte ich ja ich hätte vielleicht statt
großes Latinum ein boxkurs machen sollen
und wenn ich jemals noch die Gelegenheit
dazu habe weil sie mich fürs Boxen ich
finde ihre Beschreibung absolut aber
finden Sie es und dafür da kennt man
sehr finden Sie es nicht so schlecht das
ist diese
pazifizierung schlecht absolut schlecht
absolut schlecht wir erleben das jetzt
im Zusammenhang Putin wir werden
vielleicht später darüber reden hier hat
der Aggressor einen Bonus weil er
handelt und denjenige der sich
verteidigt hat einen Malus weil er die
Eskalation der Gewalt weiter treibt also
einem Opfer wird geraten sich
unauffällig zu benehmen und nicht allzu
viel Widerstand auszuüben dann ist es
schneller vorbei und das ist ja auch
passiert stellen sich vor Pocher hätte
zurückgeschlagen dass wir dann schon
eine Miniserie geworden nicht das wäre
dann in Raten bei RTL laufen es würde
eine Massenschlägerei geworden und es
wäre eine Massenschlägerei geworden und
ich liebe das auch da würde ehrlich
gesagt den Gedanken und nicht auf den
politischen Gedanken den sie äußern dass
wir hier ja quasi in einer Miniatur
sehen was der Ukraine passiert mit einem
Aggressor und ohne sozusagen das jemand
bei springt ist auch noch nie
aufgefallen dass man nicht viel Fantasie
und die um die Analogie noch nie
aufgefallen das ist so ist also ich
eine eine ein neues Debatten Kappel
gefunden das merkt man jetzt schon aber
wir wollen trotzdem auch noch mal zu
Herr Palma nach Tübingen schalten einmal
und die Frage stellen die finde ich sehr
spannend den Gedanken den sie
eingeworfen haben
ich sehr spannend den anderen natürlich
auch aber den spannendsten Gedanken fand
ich daran wie sehen Sie das denn mit der
Entmilitarisierung der Gesellschaft und
auch mit dem Pazifismus in der
Gesellschaft was der Bruder angesprochen
hat und danach mit Klaus Strunz
debattiert hat
sehr anders also ich halte das für eine
Errungenschaft wenn die Gesellschaft die
Gewalt mehr und mehr zurückdrängt
pazifizierung ist ja nur ein
komplizierter Begriff dafür dass man die
Dinge nicht mehr mit dem fahrstrich
regelt sondern sagt das kommt bei uns
nicht vor und wenn jemand Gewalt ausübt
dann ist es der Staat durch seine
Polizei sonst aber niemand das halte ich
erstmal von der Errungenschaft und finde
das gut dass man nicht einfach so auf
der Straße damit rechnen muss dass er
mit irgendwelche Leute umhauen und dann
die anderen dazu kommen und sagen naja
war meine Straßenschlacht draußen den
ich mich nicht zurück aber trotzdem hat
der Bruder sich an einer Stelle einen
Punkt das darf nicht dazu führen dass
Opferschutz loswerden und da muss ich
Ihnen leider sagen die Erfahrung habe
ich schon öfter gemacht ich bin leider
als Oberbürgermeister immer wieder auch
täglich angegriffen worden und es ist
mir nie jemand zur Seite gesprungen
auf der Straße ja
und es ist nie also sie haben nie deinen
Schutz erfahren von anderen die daneben
standen ne da war ich immer alleine es
gab immer Leute dabei standen und
erstaunt waren und geguckt haben aber
das war eine eingeschritten wäre zu
meinen Gunsten es kam mir vor
und welche was hinterlässtes bei ihnen
sozusagen
öfter ins
Fitnesscenter gehen und Muskeltraining
damit man sich selber verteidigen kann
oder
das ist ja sie sprechen so gelassen aus
aber das ist ja im Grunde schrecklich
es wurde nie bedrohlich dass ich
tatsächlich mal zusammengeschlagen
worden wäre sondern es war immer nur
davor ja also eben physische Bedrohung
die Blubber waren auch mal ein
cross-check oder
hinterherlaufen Pflege andere und das
hat alles gegeben es ist nicht dazu
gekommen dass ich je ernsthaft verletzt
worden wäre sonst würde ich halt
wahrscheinlich anders drüber sprechen
aber wie gehe ich damit um also ich sage
Ihnen ganz offen ich Klammer das aus
wenn man diese Gefahr die irgendwie als
Person der Öffentlichkeit halt latent
besteht dass man da auf offener Straße
angegriffen wird wenn man die nicht
verdrängen kann dann kann man eigentlich
nicht mehr dem Amt nachgehen und ich
will mich davon einfach nicht beirren
lassen